the most famous club in the world a lot
of people can't get tickets they sell
out every single show they do so I just
thought it'd be a cool thing cuz a lot
of times people go what's the difference
between the rooms and stuff I thought
I'd just kind of showcase why each room
looks that way and also as a comedian
like kind of how it feels when you're
just bouncing around like I didn't want
to I didn't want to really make it like
a documentary style thing I just wanted
to show as many jokes as possible in
that and just show kind of like oh you
run into some Comics you know and
there's some other Comics you know but
it's just all kind of imp passing while
we're uh while we're going to work